in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I show how to extend tracing to
every aspect of your cloud native
application we'll our performance stay
inside the lines stay tuned to find out
one of my favorite things about managed
services like App Engine is that your
requests are automatically traced
letting you look at a given request and
see where various execution time is
going without you having to write any
code yourself sadly if you wanted the
same sort of data for your non managed
services it meant a lot of custom code
custom deployments and a whole new team
to write a custom dashboard UI for you
but not anymore stackdriver has recently
released a library which allows your
non-managed code to get the same tracing
awesomeness with less hassle to you
using the newly created open census
library you can get instrumentation data
from any VMs or containers running in
your application across a number of
languages including Java Python nodejs
golang and more heck you could even run
it on your non Google cloud services and
get that data to the client-side library
works by patching well-known modules in
your application in order to label and
measure latency of our pcs and incoming
requests and for the not so well-known
functions you can also add custom spans
to your code they catch the important
bits that fall between all that data is
then collected and displayed in a nice
consistent UI in the cloud console to
help you track down where your
performance is going if you're
interested in getting started with stack
driver tracing check out the article
linked in the description below and
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great cloud performance
Atlas content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts